esta gráfica nos muestra la relación
entre horas de ejercicio y horas frente
a una pantalla en jueves para un grupo
de cinco amigos si miramos esto podemos
ver que aquí en el eje horizontal cuando
vamos de izquierda a derecha dice horas
de ejercicio media hora una hora una
hora y media dos horas dos horas y media
y luego este lado nos muestra las horas
frente a una pantalla así que por
ejemplo parece que isabel hizo cero
horas de ejercicio no hizo ejercicio y
pasó siete horas en frente de una
pantalla no es algo que yo recomendaría
y parece que katia paso media hora
haciendo ejercicio el jueves todo esto
describe lo que pasó el jueves y pasó
cinco horas y media en frente de una
pantalla podemos ver esto aquí y
continuar con los siguientes puntos de
nuestra información pero veamos que es
lo que nos preguntan cuál es el
significado del punto que dice maría
entonces maría está aquí y parece que
este es el punto 1 porque nuestra
coordenada horizontal está justo en el 1
y luego nuestra coordenada vertical es 4
el punto en 14 y este 1 es la hora de
ejercicio así que maría hace una hora de
ejercicio
y pasó cuatro horas frente a la pantalla
ese jueves cuatro horas frente a la
pantalla
muy bien déjenme ver cuál de esas
opciones dice eso veamos esta dice que
maría hizo una hora de ejercicio y
cuatro horas frente a la pantalla si
ésta parece correcta y si queremos
podemos revisar las otras maría hizo dos
horas de ejercicio y ocho horas frente a
la pantalla
eso sería tener el punto aquí y el punto
no está aquí así que esta la descartamos
maría hizo cuatro horas de ejercicio y
una hora frente a la pantalla cuatro
horas de ejercicio tampoco es esta
opción tendríamos que salir de la
pantalla así que descartamos esta maria
hizo cinco horas de ejercicio una vez
más esta no está en la pantalla así que
la podemos descartar esta tercera opción
está tratando de confundirnos porque
están intercambiando las horas de
ejercicio y las de pantalla maría hizo
una hora de ejercicio y cuatro horas
frente a la pantalla no cuatro horas de
ejercicio y una frente a la pantalla